be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so what I want to do here is cover the
fourth part of Marvel's Secret Wars but
because we've already done a video on
why Secret Wars was launched in the
first place and because of the fact that
we don't yet know what the fallout of
the inclusion of this comic is going to
be what we're going to do here is we're
just going to basically cover this story
and as the events unfold in future
publications we'll tie those in to give
a more well-rounded understanding of
what else going on here
in secret Wars number three we had
discussed that following the collapse of
the multiverse ultimate universe Reed
Richards
Thanos name of the Submariner and the
rest of the cabal from the mainstream
Marvel Universe had escaped the collapse
using a raft from the ultimate universe
itself in addition to this a Peter
Parker Captain Marvel Black Panther Thor
Jane Foster
star-lord Scott Summers as the Phoenix
force and Reed Richards had all survived
the collapse in a second draft from the
mainstream Marvel Universe and while
eight years had passed on the outside
only a few hours had passed inside the
laughs and so when Thanos his group
emerged and after being met with the
arrival of a contingent of the Thor core
operating as a police of battle world
Thanos and the Cabal killed all of them
and then left the area now where Secret
Wars number three had ended on the
arrival of the remaining thwart for
after tracking down Thanos and his group
following their massacre The Secret Wars
number four picks up with Doctor Strange
providing a narrative relating to the
formation of this new world
what Doctor Strange tells us is that
following the multiversal collapse Doom
Doctor Strange and the molecule man Owen
Reese had killed the beyonders the
orchestrators of the great multiversal
collapse and taking their power do
reshape reality and form battleworld of
the process by taking what was left of
alternate universes and placing them in
a singular location although we're not
told exactly how it was he was able to
accomplish all of this while Doctor
Strange serves doom as his
second-in-command his stance on the
function of battle world seems to be a
disappointment and that his view of the
world being a place of constant struggle
and strife is a far cry from what it
should have actually been now while the
group debates the decision of Doctor
Strange in turning away from omnipotence
and allowing doom to take the mantle
instead the hammer of one of the four
core recruits lights up indicating a
request for aid from those battling
Thanos at this point the story
transitions to one of the Thor core
members speaking directly with Doom
informing him that the battle with
Thanos goes poorly
while the group may be successful it
would cost the lives of many of the Thor
Court members in order to defeat Thanos
himself in addition to this when Valeri
Richards is asked by doom to use her
vast intelligence to analyze the
situation
Valerius states that the result of this
battle is impossible to determine the
power wielded by Thanos from the
mainstream Marvel Universe Dwarfs any of
his alternate reality counterparts that
currently exist on battleworld
while doom states that such a conflict
is below his concern the Susan storm
tells him that the power demonstrated by
these individuals goes beyond everyone
present on battleworld
safe doom himself and maybe dr. strange
while doom debates whether to act or not
he witnesses the arrival of Doctor
Strange on the battlefield alongside the
heroes from the mainstream Marvel
Universe and Miles Morales from the
Ultimate Universe however with the
arrival of Doctor Strange and his forces
also comes the arrival of Reed Richards
from the mainstream Marvel Universe and
after stating that he has spent years
searching every corner of battle world
for him doom states that he's finally
managed to find him taking his time to
act
doom appears on the battlefield
confronting all forces involved while he
explains to read that his new power
makes him a virtual God if Thanos
responds by simply stating that there
exists a difference between playing God
and truly being a god in addition to
this Scott Summers attacks dr. doom
stating that doom is like every man
playing with a power that he doesn't
understand with a planet being composed
of a multitude of realities each one
home to its own occupants doom is forced
himself into the role of a leader with
no true understanding of what it means
to lead that while Scott Summers is able
to hold his own against a doom for a
time Doom is able to overpower Scott
Summers and in the process season by the
neck and breaks it killing him in the
process during the entire conflict
between doom and Scott Summers however
Doctor Strange takes the opportunity to
use his power and send the various
heroes and villains away to various
places in battle world although we don't
know how
now when asked by Duma as to why he had
done this Doctor Strange simply replies
that doom would have inevitably killed
them all due to the fact that they would
never have bent their knees to his power
the furthermore Doctor Strange touches
on the inherent fear of doom in that
after all the power he's gained and his
stance as a ruler of this new reality
that in the end he still fears Reed
Richards and so in response to what
seems to be the incorrigible nature or
perhaps the insubordinate nature of
Doctor Strange Doctor Doom kills him
entirely with that being said that BRE
is an end to secret Wars number four and
we won't find out what happens until
part 5 but again we're covering each of
these as the stories are released to us
so I can't tell you exactly when that
next issue is going to come out would
that being said I will catch you guys
later peace